لماذا فعلت ذلك ، لم أكن أعتقد أن
هناك أي مخاطرة في تجربتها ، نعم
لم أسمع أبدًا عن أي شخص لديه أي
آثار سلبية منه ، لذلك
اعتقدت أنه ليس لدي ما أخسره ، لقد قمت
بإخراج نفثتين منه.  أعلم
أنني أشعر بالجنون وأفكر
بشكل مستقيم وتمكنت من التحرك في
غضون ثوانٍ ، بدا أن J قد فقد
وعيه وبدأ
يصاب بهلوسة مخيفة
قاده صديقه إلى مركز ليكسينغتون الطبي
حيث بدأ يعاني من نوبات  في
مقياس غلاسكو للغيبوبة ، قالوا إنني
سجلت في 3 ، لذا فإن 15 أمرًا طبيعيًا
و 3 ميت دماغًا بشكل أساسي نعم ، يا
إلهي سانجاي يبدو أن هذا
الشاب مات تقريبًا من اتفاقية التنوع البيولوجي ، تبدو
هذه قصة مثيرة للاهتمام حقًا ربما واحدة
من أهم القصص هنا أن
اتفاقية التنوع البيولوجي آمنة بشكل عام ، اتفاقية التنوع البيولوجي غير
ذات تأثير نفسي كما ذكرت أنه يمكن أن
يكون دواء المشكلة
والمشكلة التي تحدث ، وبالنسبة لكثير من
الناس هي أن هذه لم تكن اتفاقية التنوع البيولوجي التي
ذهب واشترى هذا في  احصائيات الغاز  دفع أيون
مقابل بطاقة ائتمان كنت تعرف أنه
كان يفعل كل شيء بشكل صحيح عندما
تم اختبار هذا المنتج لاحقًا ، ولم
يكن يحتوي على اتفاقية التنوع البيولوجي على الإطلاق ، لقد كان منتجًا
صناعيًا بالكامل وهذا جزء من المشكلة في
الوقت الحالي ، أصبح هذا متاحًا على نطاق واسع من قبل
الأشخاص الذين يشترونه  جميع أنواع
المتاجر التي تحتاج إلى أن تضعها في اعتبارك أنه
لا يوجد حقًا أي تنظيم حول هذا الأمر ،
ولا توجد لائحة تتطلب أن تكون هذه
المنتجات أصلية بحيث تكون
آمنة حتى يتم اختبارها مسبقًا ، لذلك